Darius wrote to me and said what's your
opinion about honking the horn in a car
especially in traffic jams or other
situations do you do it how do you react
to other people doing it I barely ever
use my horn and I think it's completely
counterproductive I don't get why people
are using their horn particularly in a
traffic jam where is anybody going to go
I've been in many situations even on
highways Pat where it's just a traffic
jam right there's no decisions to be
made there's nothing to do whatsoever
and all of a sudden people are honking
and not not necessarily even at me but
like the person next to me is honking
people up front or further behind I
don't get the point of it and I
incredibly rarely use my horn I will do
it if someone and here in Boston there's
a lot of really bad driving if someone
is doing something insanely dangerous
like as I'm driving straight ahead in my
lane someone with no signal starts to
sort of drift over i will do a sustained
horn honk there and usually that will
get them to go back into their lane and
i'm very specifically trying to avoid an
accident right but the sort of honking
to complain about you know things that
are barely even a blip on the radar i
try to restrict my hot horn honking well
you're very polite it seems as a driver
yeah i think just growing up in the
boston area i have kind of taken over
the the idea that you have to be for any
small infraction that someone else
commits really i have this idea that
there really should be two different
kinds of horns one should be in case
that near accident is gonna happen and
you have to warn the other driver like
the normal horn right and maybe another
friendly one to say oh the Red the light
has turned green you should start going
now or to say hi to your friends I mean
I think we need two different ones it's
not a bad idea i mean the problem is
every car already has a different
sounding horn so then you'd be talking
about you know twice as many iterations
i did have a like a not a rude awakening
but i was re-appointed with the use of
the horn when i was driving during my
trip to Italy in September because there
with all of the motorcycles and scooters
that are constantly diving in and out
and in between cars their horns are
actually used very regularly sort of as
like a hey I'm here type of of message
like just so you know I'm here because
people are constantly weaving and in the
Amalfi Coast the roads are so narrow and
windy that often you can't
actually see around the curb the curve
rather and the horn is also used to warn
people to sometimes you would drive not
right off to the side but you would
drift sort of to the middle of the road
a little bit because it is so narrow and
when you're coming around these curves
you use your horn just to let oncoming
traffic know that you're there at first
it was very distracting because there's
constant horn honking but it's a totally
different application there yeah and for
the most part that's covered here by
flashing lights right a lot of people if
they're they're warning someone about
something about in the row that's going
on right something that they have to pay
attention to they'll just flash their
lights really quick and I do that all
the time I have one friend who drives
with one hand on the horn because he
wants to be he believes that driving is
sort of like dog training where if you
don't provide the feedback immediately
the the same way the dog doesn't realize
what it's being scolded for unless you
scolded immediately the driver won't
connect whatever action they did to
being scolded by the horn so he drives
with one hand on the wheel at about ten
o'clock and another hand right on the
horn to be able to instantly honk at
other cars I don't know that he's really
doing uh God's work so to speak in
informing people and improving their
driving I think people have no idea what
he's doing but this is his tactic anyway
and I'm sure he's a perfect driver never
makes a mistake in that never has to
hear the warning himself reports are
that he's quite a good driver let's get
to know all right we have a great bonus
show for you today uh were were so out
of time I won't even tell you what's on
it but what I will tell you is 2017
david pakman show calendars are
available at david pakman.com slash
calendar 17 and if you want the calendar
for free you can also get it with a
yearly membership